[Music]
future film foreshadowing environmental
rage and red herring that caught us all
off guard these brief lines in avatar
The Way of water hold an ocean of depth
both Avatar films have a similar framing
device they begin and end with Jake
Sully's narration in the prologue of the
way of water Jake waxes poetic about his
beautiful wife and beloved children
besides naturi his family has grown to
include adopted daughter Kiri oldest son
to Tam youngest son laloc and youngest
daughter took viewers get the sense that
after the traumatic destruction of Home
tree nature and the navi people are
healing together but then he warns the
most dangerous thing about Pandora is
that you might grow to love her too much
by this she means his family the navi
Community that's taken him in and the
natural beauty and scientific wonder of
the Moon they all live on Jake often
tells me teary that he loves her in
conjunction with her people in their
world it makes sense that he speaks this
way the navi know that everything on
Pandora is connected his fear of losing
his happiness is a fear of losing his
family his clan and his new Homeworld so
when Jake's monologue ends with the line
the thing about happiness is it can
vanish in a heartbeat he's referring to
his own as well as that of everyone he
loves including AWA the great mother
what does Ava's heartbeat sound like
Mighty the quote is tragic foreshadowing
indicating that someone's heartbeat is
soon to stop in his opening monologue
Jake catches the audience up to speed on
what he and the rest of the Sully Cline
have been up to for the last decade and
a half the audience sees him welcoming
his children into the world teaching
them how to hunt and fish and
accompanying natiri on a Twilight
Banshee ride date night as Jake
describes each milestone in English the
rest of the navi communicate with one
another using the language Cameron and a
linguist invented for the franchise Jake
jokes about how long it took him to
speak the language fluently he concludes
by saying that now it might as well be
English in that moment Jake's family's
dialogue switches to English even though
the audience is meant to understand that
they're all speaking Navi this is a
slick screenwriting trick a way to
acknowledge and preserve Pandora's
on-screen culture without making the
actors do the entirety of their perform
in a fictional language the remainder of
Avatar the way of water is spoken almost
entirely in English except for moments
where what's Lost in Translation is part
of the plot
Jake admits that although he and his
kids love spider a feral boy left behind
by the humans naturi struggles to see
him as anything but an outsider and a
threat at the beginning the audience
doesn't know if she's aware of the truth
about his parentage but by the end it's
clear that some of her hesitation about
accepting the boy into their family has
to do with the fact that he's gorgeous
son it was nitiri who dealt the depraved
Colonel a fatal blow with her father's
bow and arrow at the end of the original
Avatar which we see play out again on
the mech suit camera later recombinant
quarrej lands on Pandora to seek revenge
on the traitor Jake Sully he essentially
looks into kidnapping the silly kids at
the site of the old mobile lab discovers
naturi was responsible for his death and
is nearly able to take her out all in
the same scene before his plan is
interrupted he shouts in her direction
that he recognizes her call sign the
color of the flutches on her arrows she
recognizes his voice and though she's
confused yells back I will kill you as
many times as I have to at the end of
the film Jake and atiri think
recombinant courage is at the bottom of
the ocean but since spider couldn't
bring himself to let him die he'll most
certainly be back in Avatar 3. there's a
great deal of talk about the life cycle
in the way of water and it begins long
before the sullies get to the reef after
their encounter with recombinant courage
Jake realizes the humans are
specifically targeting his family and
decides the best course of action for
the sullies and for the umatakaya is for
them to leave this is easier said than
done he's clan leader according to their
Traditions the old leader must die
before the new one can assume his place
something Jake learned firsthand all
those years ago
kill you
it is the way
[Music]
and it is good
Tarzan the incoming a matakaya leader
ceremonially slashes Jake across the
chest and says one life ends another
begins with that the Sully family takes
to their banshees for Parts Unknown
throughout the film there are a number
of hints that Jake may meet his untimely
end and this reference to his own
symbolic death is just one of them Jake
frequently talks about protecting his
family at all costs which primes viewers
to think he's going to make the ultimate
sacrifice when it comes down to it to
save his children and his people that's
exactly what the plot sets up in its
third act courage is Jake's kids captive
on the sea dragon and he's only willing
to exchange them for Jake's life of
course the emphasis on Jake's mortality
is a red herring tragically it's Jake
and atiri's oldest son netam who doesn't
survive the battle when the sullies
arrive safely at The Reef Jake feels
relatively confident that the mechaena
people will grant them shelter after all
he was the great Turok mocto until very
recently tonawari the leader of the
mechaina knows of his Legend and is
welcoming but is also concerned about
the possibility of War coming to his
Shores his wife and the Clan's Medicine
Woman Ronald is much more skeptical she
correctly deduces that the sullies had
to leave high camp because they posed a
problem to the marikaya and she doesn't
want to bother teaching her ways to
people who won't be receptive or capable
she tells tonawari they will be like
babies this line is a callback to when
Jake and natiri meet in the first avatar
you're like a baby
what nitiri means is that Jake was loud
clumsy and unaware of his impact on the
world around him when her mother charged
her with teaching Jake the ways of the
navi she bristled reasoning that they'd
essentially have to start from scratch
now the tables are turned while Ronald's
daughter sorea is noticeably more up for
the challenge Ronald still asserts that
it won't be easy for the forest Navi to
fit in at The Reef her comment is both a
statement of prejudice and a reasonable
attempt at isolating her clan from
danger two themes seen consistently
throughout the Avatar series
the flip side of Bruno's line is Jake's
answer to it he tells the mechaina we
will adapt Jake has adapted before and
he'll do it again he did it as a human
after becoming paralyzed again when he
was reborn as a navi Avatar and once
more when he was finally accepted into
Navi Society with a permanent true Navi
body of his own Jake is also pointing
out that on a long enough timeline the
navi physically Adept Evolution has made
the navi distinct from each other
depending on the habitat in which they
lived the Met kaina have evolved to have
lighter teal skin thicker and flatter
Tails muscular almost thin wrists and
bigger lungs they've adapted to their
ecosystem as will the clans of Navi that
audiences are likely to meet in Avatar 3
and Beyond given his circumstances Jake
is much less prejudiced about physical
differences than other Navi the Avatar
films are deeply interested in the
intersections between technology biology
and environmental science messages can
be found throughout that not so
discreetly plead with humans to to be
better stewards of their resources their
planet and each other Cameron is
challenging humans to evolve to live
within what Jake calls the great balance
rather than to continue old destructive
habits
if Avatar the way of water has a thesis
statement it's the words of the mechanic
people wisdom that Soraya imparts to a
troubled loock she tells him the way of
water has no beginning and no end water
connects all things life to death
Darkness to light she goes on to compare
water to a womb that births us into a
world which exists before we're here and
remains after we die it's a moving
speech made even more Lovely by the
actors calm contemplative delivery and
the entrancing shots of Pandora's Marine
Wildlife alien that's all they see
surah's lesson is meant to make loock
feel as though he's a part of something
bigger than himself and his family more
broadly it's meant to teach the forest
dwelling sullies about her Clan's
specific philosophy when it comes to the
great balance that Jake speaks of the
great balance that Earth's humans don't
respect these mechaina sentiments are
religious in world but they also
represent the environmentally conscious
Cameron's personal philosophy if that
philosophy sounds strikingly similar to
the notion of the force from Star Wars
especially as is a more mature and
slightly jaded Luke Skywalker taught it
to Ray in The Last Jedi you're not alone
both borrow from Eastern spiritual
Traditions like taoism and the
pantheistic religions that Revere nature
Pandora's sky is one of its most
spectacular yet fraught features instead
of days and nights with the sun followed
by a moon up above this habitable moon
has an enormous planet on its Horizon it
has nightly eclipses and some peculiar
Seasons but like any big rock floating
in space its sky is full of stars lawak
trying to make his father sound like a
hero for once remarks my dad came from a
star it's a touching moment in theory
the lock not only views his once human
father as a true Navi but that he's
mythologized his origin story to an
extent that he'd probably never actually
admit but in the past 30 years what
appeared to be falling stars turned out
to be spacecraft from Earth sent mostly
for nefarious purposes it's the white
light of a ship burning its way into
Pandora's atmosphere that alerts Jake
and natiri to the return of the humans
at the start of the way of water the
humans are returning they're hunting us
and since the audience knows that Earth
is dying and humans have little choice
but to take over this distant Moon by
any means necessary it's not the last
time these young Navi will see an
ominous star in Pandora's sky
CH convinces his sort of sun spider to
Ride Along on his squad's mission in
order to avoid the military's mental
torture he remains antagonistic to their
efforts throughout his captivity making
fun of their slow speed and poor
understanding of the navi language he's
a tarzan-like teen among 10 foot tall
blue jarheads until he meets marine
biologist Dr Ian Garvin as heartless and
hot-headed Alphas quartz and Captain
Mick excitedly discuss the killing and
harvesting of tolkiens a more subdued
and guilt-ridden Dr Garvin walks through
each step of the operation with spider
once their target the mother Tolkien
that was Ronald's Spirit sister has been
eliminated The Hunting Party Ventures
inside her corpse where makeshift
workspace has been set up the team
drills into the tolkien's brain and out
comes a golden liquid about enough to
fill a thermos Captain Mick claims it's
worth about 80 million dollars it turns
out earth scientists have discovered
this substance has the power to stop
human aging spider has an issue with
this though he asks in Rage you just
waste the rest this is meant to show how
irresponsible modern industrialized
humans are compared to indigenous
populations who live in harmony with
their natural resources the whaling
operations wastefulness is even more
horrific once the film explains how
acutely tolkiens are able to think and
feel